The economy is collapsing and corona virus
is exploding, and the next three months could
be a disaster.
We have now seen the Dow Jones Industrial
Average dropped more than eight percent in
the last couple of weeks.
We have seen even after the supposed record
setting, delightful, fantastic GDP numbers
of the third quarter, we still are down more
than eight points annualized from where we
were GDP wise before the pandemic.
We are only getting into what is predicted
to be the worst period in the United States
from a public health standpoint in literally
100 hundred years.
Dr. Anthony Foushee said six months ago, if
we don't get this under control.
We are talking about 100000 cases per day
come fall.
And Trump has said no way.
And Republicans said no way.
And Trump said Foushee doesn't always know
what he's talking about.
And yet, Friday, we saw for the first time
ever, 100000 cases in a single day, more than
100, 1000, in fact.
But what's a thousand cases between friends
at this point?
But but but the deaths aren't going to climb.
They said, well, it takes three or more weeks
to see the death numbers climb, but they already
are.
As we've seen, the seven day moving average
of deaths bottom out around October 17th and
start to trickle up, up, up and likely to
continue.
And this is not because we're doing more testing.
This is what Trump is claiming.
We're finding more cases because we've upped
testing.
Testing is up seven percent in the last week.
Cases are up 19 percent.
Testing is up seven percent.
In the last week.
Hospitalizations are up 13 percent.
It is not testing in the month of October.
Only Georgia and Hawaii saw decreases in hospitalization.
California was steady.
Every other state saw increases in hospitalization.
We have an administration that has no plan
to deal with the virus, but also doesn't even
understand that if their focus is the economy,
you have to deal with the virus.
If deaths double to where we're seeing two
thousand twenty five hundred deaths per day
for one month, two months, three months, things
are going to have to shut down.
Businesses are going to have to shutter.
That will be a disaster for the economy.
Now, Trump may be a lame duck president by
then.
If he loses tomorrow or he may be reelected
president and rewarded with four more years
despite having no plan.
And listen, if he can get reelected with no
plan, you can bet your ass that he's not going
to then come up with a plan.
He'll have been reelected.
He will see it as a referendum that went his
way on his handling of Corona virus.
So the economy rides on tomorrow's election.
The handling of the virus and America's public
health rides on the handling of the election.
Trade policy, international alliances.
The perception of the United States as a sane
and sensible country.
It's all riding on tomorrow's election.
I'll be streaming results live starting at
7:00 p.m. Eastern tomorrow, Tuesday on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook.
I hope you will join me.
Let me know how your vote went on Twitter,
where you can find me at David Pakman.